[Música]
eeuu condenó a cadena perpetua a el saf
y el sheikh uno de los terroristas de
una célula del autodenominado estado
islámico acusada de secuestrar y
asesinar a cuatro ciudadanos
estadounidenses durante la guerra en
siria
la fiscalía mexicana detuvo a jesús
murillo karam ex procurador general de
la república el ex funcionario está
relacionado con la desaparición de los
43 estudiantes de ayotzinapa cuyo caso
fue catalogado como un crimen de estado
en el marco del estado de excepción en
guayaquil tras los hechos de violencia
reciente vamos a 'ciudad de dios' un
barrio popular en la periferia en donde
queda en evidencia la difícil situación
social que permite el fortalecimiento de
los grupos delincuenciales
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 soy rodrigo sedano y estas son
las noticias más destacadas del
continente americano este viernes un
tribunal estadounidense condenó a cadena
perpetua a el saf y el 61 de los
terroristas de una célula del
autodenominado estado islámico que
durante la guerra siria secuestró y
asesinó a cuatro ciudadanos
estadounidenses en decapitaciones
difundidas en internet
marta moya con los detalles
una sentencia que alivia este viernes un
tribunal del estado de virginia en eeuu
falló cadena perpetua para uno de los
integrantes de la célula conocida como
los beatles perteneciente al
autodenominado estado islámico en el que
esta sentencia deje claro a todos los
que se atrevan a secuestrar torturar o
matar a cualquier ciudadano
estadounidense del extranjero que la
justicia de eeuu les encontrara donde
quiera que estén y que nuestro gobierno
les hará rendir cuentas por sus crímenes
contra nuestros ciudadanos
en el curso de la guerra siria cuatro
ciudadanos estadounidenses fueron
tomados como rehenes por esta célula
terrorista y tres de ellos fueron
posteriormente ejecutados en
decapitaciones grabadas en vídeo y
difundidas en internet el saf y el
sheikh quien recibió el castigo a cadena
perpetua este viernes es un ex ciudadano
británico al que la justicia de ese país
declaró culpable en abril por toma de
rehenes con resultado de muerte
off llevó como muchos de ustedes saben
tuvimos que suprimir la opción de la
pena de muerte debido a las leyes
británicas así que creo que el castigo
se ajusta al crimen en este caso
absolutamente por lo que son los
estadounidenses y a todos los demás
rehenes pasará el resto de sus días en
una celda y tendrá tiempo para
considerar lo que ha hecho
el site es el miembro de más alto rango
del grupo estado islámico en ser
condenado por un tribunal en eeuu sin
embargo dicho tribunal descartó pedir la
pena de muerte como parte de un acuerdo
que garantizaba su extradición
entretanto en mexico la fiscalía general
detuvo al ex titular de la extinta
procuraduría general de la republica
jesús murillo karam el ex funcionario
está relacionado con la desaparición de
los 43 estudiantes de ayotzinapa y su
arresto se da por los delitos de
desaparición forzada tortura y contra la
administración de justicia su detención
tiene lugar después de que la comisión
creada para esclarecer el caso de los 43
estudiantes catalogar a su desaparición
como un crimen de estado el presidente
mexicano andrés manuel lópez obrador se
refirió a este tema
dar a conocer la verdad fortalece a las
instituciones
y castigar a los responsables
desde luego el caso no está cerrado
y nos vamos hasta nicaragua allí la
denominada persecución contra la iglesia
católica llevó este viernes a la
detención del obispo de matagalpa
rolando álvarez junto a otras siete
personas cercanas retenidas desde el 4
de agosto el obispo es un conocido
criticó al gobierno de daniel ortega y
rosario murillo previamente nuestro
corresponsal en centroamérica andrés
suárez jaramillo nos contaba cuáles son
los argumentos del gobierno para
arrestar a monseñor rolando álvarez y
por qué su captura ha generado tanta
conmoción internacional pretendía el
reciente daniel ortega ha calificado a
los obispos de nicaragua como
terroristas como golpistas que incitan
al odio pero en el caso puntual de
monseñor rolando álvarez la policía
nacional emitió un comunicado en el cual
relaciona a este obispo con actividades
desestabilizadoras y provocadoras y aquí
es importante hacer una inflexión para
decir que nicaragua es un país
centroamericano
significativamente católico israelí que
tiene mucha influencia los obispos los
sacerdotes en la opinión de la sociedad
nicaragüense y aunque esa separación de
iglesia y estado que ocurrió hace más de
dos siglos con la ilustración en la cual
ese divorcio entre el trono y el altar
un divorcio legal y político no se ha
dado del todo en nicaragua dado que los
sacerdotes y en el caso de rolando
álvarez pues influyen mucho en los temas
políticos y sociales del país por
ejemplo hablan de temas de emigración
del tema de los presos políticos de el
tema de los exiliados basta con revisar
las redes sociales por ejemplo de
monseñor álvarez para darse cuenta de
esto en donde él por ejemplo
hace uso de una retórica reiterativa de
la eucaristía haciendo la distinción
entre el bien y el mal entre el infierno
el cielo entre el enemigo y el vencedor
dios y aunque el propiamente no habla de
ortega son sus seguidores quienes
relacionan todos estos comentarios
del obispo con lo que sucede en el país
de manera que se podría hablar de una
falta de libertad de expresión que
enciende las alarmas en diferentes
sectores internacionales
el pasado domingo ecuador vivió un nuevo
episodio de la escalada de violencia que
afecta al país una bomba explotó en una
zona residencial de guayaquil donde el
gobierno de guillermo lasso decretó el
estado de excepción el principal puerto
ecuatoriano vive una crisis de seguridad
donde las bandas narcotraficantes se
sienten presentes en toda la ciudad luís
muñoz con la historia de 'ciudad de
dios' un barrio en las montañas de la
ciudad
es ciudad de dios pero no es en brasil
es un asentamiento de guayaquil ecuador
fue poblado por evangélicos protestantes
allí viven 40.000 personas sin servicios
básicos en viviendas precarias hacinados
y rodeados de violencia la onu llama a
esto una trampa de pobreza de la que
difícilmente se puede escapar es de ahí
hay otros temas asociadas en temas de
salud bien hay una alta proliferación de
enfermedades el tema educativo también
es grave en ciudad de dios pertenece a
monte sinaí en las montañas de la ciudad
donde viven 500.000 personas
hay 55 asentamientos irregulares pero
también organizaciones criminales en
este 2022 ha habido 861 homicidios es el
32 por ciento del total del país una
gran inseguridad
imaginen por bañarme hasta me pueden
hacer volar yo yo antes vivía en un
bañito
era un bañito de plástico que cualquiera
metía la mano desgarrada me platicó que
no me hacía
guayaquil es el principal puerto al
pacífico de ecuador lo que la convierte
en un centro mundial de distribución de
cocaína bandas de narcos tienen
presencias en las calles en las
prisiones y en las montañas por lo que
tras una bomba el pasado domingo el
gobierno decretó el estado de excepción
ante la crisis de seguridad interna la
zona del delta del río paraná en
argentina enfrenta un incendio forestal
de gran tamaño debido a la sequía
prolongada las llamas comenzaron debido
a que los agricultores de la zona
realizaron quemas para preparar los
terrenos para nuevas cosechas las
enormes columnas de columnas de humo han
afectado las ciudades de rosario y la
capital buenos aires
un incendio en argentina pone en riesgo
los ecosistemas de los humedales del
delta del río paraná y a los habitantes
de la región de rosario a la vegetación
de adentro de una aleación gateo
terrible
y además de con las rotaciones del
viento hace que el humo venga hacia la
ciudad e impactan este gran rosario que
hay casi 700 personas viviendo en
estaciones indudablemente es muy dañino
para ellos y eso nos producto muchísimo
el fuego afecta cada año esta región es
iniciado en gran medida por agricultores
que preparan la tierra para sus cosechas
como para destacar en el año muy 20 se
quemaron más de 500 mil el año pasado
unas 110 mil bueno y ahora estamos por
debajo de cualquier manera este clima
como estaba mucho viento no llueve la
sequía ha venido en aumento en los
últimos años el río paraná el segundo
más largo y suramérica después del
amazonas es clave para el transporte de
la enorme cosecha de cereales de
argentina que sale desde la ciudad de
rosario en 2021 su nivel de agua se
redujo hasta alcanzar la menor
profundidad desde 1944
los oficiales desde principios de la
semana la gran neblina causada por los
incendios forestales del paraná llegaron
a la capital buenos aires- las
autoridades recomiendan evitar
actividades al aire libre proteger las
vías respiratorias y oculares conducir
despacio mantener la distancia y
utilizar luces bajas a principios de
este mes miles de personas salieron a
las calles de rosario para protestar
contra los incendios exigiendo la
aplicación de las leyes que los prohíben
sigan conectados a france 24
[Música]